i have a nine-year-old daughter i have
three kids
and i told my nine-year-old daughter
that i was going to be speaking with you
and i said what do you think about
the climate change climate change and
she said
the earth is on fire and we're all going
to die soon
wow she could have her own show on cnn
[Music]
[Applause]
all right should your kid take classes
from racist asses our nation's great
unifier joe biden now wants to spend
your money on critical race theory
lessons
for our country's already distressed
students this guy divides the country
more than
time zones but i guess joe's just happy
to have a job
technically he hasn't really had a job
since that dust-up with corn pop at the
municipal pool
that's why he keeps saying kamala is
president cause he's not sure if he is
they they actually installed the waze
app on his phone so he could find the
west wing
so it's no wonder the ignorant activist
class can pull his strings
lying isn't the only thing he has in
common with pinocchio
remember being told joe was a centrist
those still singing that tune look like
millie vanilli
yeah they say he's middle of the road
but if he were any more left he'd be
driving in
england the only thing middle of the
road about joe
is his hair which resembles a crushed
squirrel
it's only april and he swallowed more
anti-american crap than michael moore's
septic tank
according to the new york post the u.s
education department
whatever that is wants financial grants
to incorporate teaching and learning
practices
that reflect the diversity identities
histories contributions and experiences
of
all students you know which doesn't
sound bad
until you see their curriculum is
uniformly hard leftist brainwashed from
the debunked
1619 project to the best-selling
white-hating book
how to be an anti-racist a book so
divisive
it makes bull connor look like my little
pony
in this lesson plan social identities
are viewed as an asset
rather than a barrier to success unless
of course you're a caucasian or
asian we went to an angry white guy for
comment
nice arm packy critical race theory
i don't know they keep coming up with
theories
round the horn boys about the one i grew
up with
martin luther king where the content of
your character
is more important than your race i'll
stick with that theory
keep it simple right one and done
ooh center cut
come back now when you learn the
language of identity politics
politics it sets off your bs detector
they're obsessed with identity
unless it's an id to show you voted you
realize that it's not an education
they're after but indoctrination
while other countries focus on reading
writing innovating succeeding
we're tearing ourselves apart division
should be for math class
but no longer and if you disagree well
you're no better than a pedophile
according to this oregon teacher
so if you're being resistant i
understand that
but you're going to have to eventually
come to the light
because if you're going to keep with
those old views
of um colonialism um
it's going to lead to being fired
because you're going to be doing damage
to our children
on trauma and so as we fire the teachers
who sexually abuse our children
we will be firing the the teachers who
do
racist things to our children and
traumatize them
holy sh talk about child abuse
that's from a teacher how does she have
a job
okay if this isn't a cult i'm charles
manson
and it is a cult one that guarantees
your kids turning on each other and then
you
we used to let puberty do that it's the
revolution from within from ivy league
discrimination against asian students
to condescending lower standards for
blacks and hispanics it's a war on
achievement
and the anti-american language they use
sounds just like chinese propaganda
and not just because both are coming
from lebron james their curriculum is
exactly what our enemies would airdrop
as leaflets to undermine the cohesion of
america
so don't be surprised if your kid is
fluent in mandarin by the fourth grade
seriously imagine if our president in
the midst of the cold war
had sided with the ussr mr gorbachev
repair this wall now please join me for
our daily flag burning
that is a terrible reagan impression but
that's the way it is now a white house
that believes the country
that owns it is evil when joe says he's
here to unify he really wants us to
unify under a belief that we are racist
this from a guy who actually went to the
funeral of a kkk member
a geezer who helped put more blacks
behind bars than kamala harris
the irony is thicker than hunter's black
book
but i guess this is his own personal
reparations
because it's systemic leftism from head
to toe
this is the one old white fart the woke
can forgive
so as we endure a coveted educational
nightmare
instead of opening schools biden is
destroying them you won't know because
they're getting rid of accelerated
courses and trashing standards
altogether
the goal isn't to educate it's to
convince minorities white people are the
reason
your schools are horrible the teachers
unions are never accountable
as they fight all competition and
accountability
the only ones left unscathed are the far
left in their institutions
and this radical ideology has a built-in
survival mechanism it labels everyone
who won't play along a racist
until racism has no meaning which is why
it's key that all of us of every creed
and color stick together
and fight this dangerous nonsense
because alone
they will try to take you down quicker
than a trump 2024 yard sign
and if we don't some old white dude who
once piled around with segregationists
will use you to pay for his phony
redemption
[Music]
let's welcome tonight's guests
she puts the nice and jan nice
the meteorologist who put andrew cuomo
in a high pressure system
fox news senior meteorologist janice
don't give her no lift or she'll sink
your battleship
naval reserve officer and former state
department spokeswoman
morgan ortegas
he's so tough sharks have terry shepard
week retired green beret master sergeant
and host of hollywood weapons on outdoor
channel terry shappert
and she's so libertarian she screams
am i being detained at red lights
hosting sincerely counter box station
cat dude
all right janice you're a parent
or so i'm told i don't want to piss her
off i see what she can do
she's taking down a governor i'm with
you i'm just a talk show host
so how do you feel about all this woke
curriculum i'm nervous
yeah yeah i mean i have a 12 year old
and a 10 year old
and i listened to alvada king uh the
other day and she said what happened to
the human race yeah right we all bleed
the same
and when i was going to school you know
my best friend is
a beautiful indian woman and she's been
my best friend since you know since i
was
10 years old but we never you know i
never
looked at her differently i would go to
her house i would see her
different traditions but i love that
about her
and i never saw race and what's
happening to our kids now in school you
know i
i want them to organically love each
other and and not be
looking at each other and looking at
their skin color i wanted to i want us
to
to be colorblind again no it's funny
it's like they are
literally creating this kind of
mechanism in your brain where you cannot
not
see skin color it's now everywhere you
know terry
is this what you and i fought for side
by side
in the in the green parades in the
trenches when i saved your life numerous
times
you pulled me out of that foxhole i used
this leather pants as a tourniquet
i'm going to get to that in a minute
this is my first time on your new show
so congratulations yeah but i've been
with you since the early red
eye days and so it's not an
overstatement to say that you kind of a
lot of your success to me
yeah yeah and and that's okay you're
well you're welcome for that and what
else are you welcome for greg
my freedom your freedom you're welcome
you're welcome uh
so we can move on so the critical race
theory here's the thing if you notice
the people who are putting this crap
out whether they're black white male or
female they all have these like high
academic pedigrees from ivy league
schools and so these things are
are created and fermented in academic
circles which is insulated from reality
but they have real world effects if you
actually apply them
so that's why we see males crushing
women in sports events because if they
identify as a female
it's a it's a for number one that's
right we will always kick your ass women
so
and i don't feel bad about that but i
identify as a man so the thing is
that academic construct which is fake
and artificial applied to reality
has bad things and we see the same thing
with critical race there we just saw
a white cop save a black girl's life get
from getting stabbed from a black girl
and it was called racism we see
rioting looting murdering and killing
and assault
and it's encouraged and forgiven if the
people doing it have a certain color
that leads to lawlessness and i think
the people putting this crap out they
think they're well their egos are
involved in it they think
they're the agents of change and it will
not affect them it will affect you
the crocodile will get to you eventually
mm-hmm or alligator
uh well they're dif they're different
greg crocodiles are more aggressive
yes yes yes morgan um i hope you left
your
motorcycle out back um you're you know
you're like a country
you're a country and western hells angel
well i live in nashville now so that's
why
this is my national bag there you go um
what do you make of this do you i mean
isn't it ironic that that teacher claims
that if you
don't come to the light you're like a
pedophile that to me seems like a form
of child abuse
it's very scary i have a daughter now
they're not the age of janice
she's not genesis kids age yet but it
does make me concerned it's one of the
reasons i moved to the south i was like
i gotta get out of the craziness
and raise my kid in a normal place in
real america but it's interesting in
your monologue
you talked about chinese propaganda i
spent the last two years traveling the
world with mike pompeo
i've seen real tyranny yeah right i've
seen real countries you know what where
where i would like to take all the
teachers that were in that video and
take them to some of the countries that
i've been to
uh and leave them there but you know i
i think you know and secretary blinken
who works for biden now you know said
this to the chinese and he said you know
we have had a lot of flaws in our
history
but we work to overcome them we work to
better our society
and we're seeing instances where the
russians the chinese the iranians
they are actually uh using the divisions
in our country based on race on facebook
and
and on other social media uh outlets to
divide us
right so our enemies are using or are
using this uh language that's going on
right now to bait us
to against each other and it's it's
effective there are like dummy like
twitter
uh uh twitter handles that are like have
one or no followers that are right there
on this stage pumping this stuff out
it's got it's got to be somewhat
organized
you know uh cat did moderate joe biden
really ever exist it feels like
as a plagiarist he's basically just
become bernie sanders with you know less
hair
yeah i don't think that joe biden uh
really has views at this point i don't
think
any of the stuff that he's saying is
stuff he thought of
right i think he has people saying hey
this is what you this is the thing that
you believe and he's like okay and then
he says it
and then he goes home and does a
crossword puzzle and goes to bed yes
and i can't even really blame him
because i will not live to be that age
there's just no way it's just look if
people want their kids to learn this
they should have a school where they do
that right but i just i just we have to
get rid of the department of education
yes
and i know that everybody says thank you
people say that sounds crazy but like
what sounds crazier right all
kids are unique individuals communities
are different and every child's
different
who what's better to you know make those
decisions as parents with your kids
or just have them all educated the same
way by the feds
it doesn't it's of course it's becoming
ridiculous because it was always
ridiculous
yeah just a correction i don't think uh
president biden does crossword puzzles i
think he does the word scramble
yeah but he doesn't change any of it
hungry hungry hippos
he goes yeah this looks good to me he's
definitely he's definitely not in
control
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else